IVAN WATSON FOUND THEM AT A
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL WHERE SADLY,
MANY OTHER FAMILIES HAVE SIMILAR
STORIES.
>> Reporter: THIS 11-YEAR-OLD
LIES IN A HOSPITAL, RECOVERING
NINE DAYS AFTER A RUSSIAN
SOLDIER SHOT HER THROUGH THE
FACE.
HORRIBLY WOUNDED, AND YET QUICK
TO SHOW OFF HOW SHE CAN COUNT IN
ENGLISH.
>> 1, 2, 3, 4 --
>> Reporter: SHE CAN'T SPEAK
LOUDLY, HER MOTHER EXPLAINS.
SHE HAS A BULLET WOUND TO HER
JAW AND THE BASE OF HER TONGUE,
SHE SAYS.
THE BULLET WAS LODGED IN HER
THROAT, NEAR HER CAROTID ARTERY.
THOSE GYMNASTICS.
SHE'S GOING TO SHOW US A COUPLE
OF VIDEOS.
HERE HE IS BEFORE RUSSIA INVADED
UKRAINE.
FLIPPING AND DANCING.
BUT NOW SHE CAN BARELY WALK.
WE MET HER HERE IN A MAKESHIFT
BOMB SHELTER IN THE BASEMENT OF
A CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
THE NURSES HERE SAY SIX OR SEVEN
TIMES A DAY OR NIGHT, DUE TO AIR
RAID SIRENS, THEY HAVE TO BRING
THESE NEWBORNS WHO ALL HAVE
MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS IN AND OUT
OF THIS ROOM FOR HOURS AT A TIME
FOR THEIR SAFETY.
THE WINDOWS ARE PROTECTED BY
SANDBAGS.
ON MARCH 16th, THE WOMAN AND HER
TWO DAUGHTERS IN LAW AND
MOTHER-IN-LAW FLED AFTER
ENDURING WEEKS OF RUSSIAN
BOMBARDMENT.
JUMPING INTO THE BACK OF A CAR
WITH TWO STRANGERS TO ESCAPE.
THEY NAVIGATED MANY RUSSIAN
MILITARY CHECKPOINTS, AND THEN
AT AROUND NOON, SHE SAYS, THEY
MADE A TURN TOWARD THE TOWN AND
STUMBLED ACROSS RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
WHO OPENED FIRE ON THE CAR
WITHOUT WARNING.
>> Translator: WE STARTED
TURNING AND THAT'S WHEN THEY
STARTED FIRING AT US FROM
MACHINE GUNS.
AFTER THAT, OF COURSE, THE
DRIVER STOPPED.
WE STARTED OPENING OUR DOORS,
WALKING OUT WITH OUR HANDS UP.
AFTER WHICH THEY WERE SHOUTING
SOMETHING.
WE DID NOT KNOW WHAT.
THAT'S WHEN WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED
TO MY DAUGHTER, THE YOUNGER ONE.
WE TOOK HER OUT OF THE CAR AND
SHE WAS WOUNDED.
>> Reporter: HER MOTHER SAYS
REALIZING THEIR MISTAKE, THE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS GAVE HER
DAUGHTER FIRST-AID AND SENT HER
TO A NEARBY HOSPITAL IN THE
RUSSIAN OCCUPIED TOWN.
A RED CROSS VEHICLE LATER
BROUGHT HER TO THIS HOSPITAL FOR
LIFE-SAVING SURGERY.
THE HOSPITAL HAS TREATED NINE
WOUNDED CHILDREN IN THE LAST TWO
WEEKS.
WHAT INJURIES ARE YOU SEEING?
>> DIFFERENT INJURIES, DIFFERENT
TRAUMA.
IT IS HEAD TRAUMA, AMPUTATION,
IT IS BULLETS TRAUMA.
>> Reporter: THE DOCTOR SAYS SHE
IS NOW STABLE AND WILL LIVE.
HOPEFULLY WITHOUT LONG-TERM
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES.
>> BUT SHE HAS NOT SO GOOD
PSYCHOLOGICAL STATUS.
SHE WORRIES, SHE CRY, SHE AFRAID
DIFFERENT SOUNDS.
>> Reporter: HER MOTHER HAS A
MESSAGE FOR THE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
WHO SHOT HER DAUGHTER.
>> Translator: GO BACK HOME.
WHY ARE THEY HERE?
THEY ARE MERCENARIES WHO DON'T
CARE ABOUT US.
DON'T CARE ABOUT THE SITUATION
IN THIS COUNTRY OR THIS WAR.
THEY DON'T CARE WHO THEY ARE
SHOOTING AT.
>> Reporter: AS FOR HER, SHE
SHARES PHOTOS OF HER CATS AND